what up
people i'm dave rubin this is the
rubinport direct message
it is december 14 2020
we are covering four stories today all
over the
map of philosophy politics culture
and everything else because there is an
awful lot going on uh before
i do anything else though uh i just want
to
refute some rumors that are going around
okay there's some rumors
that i maybe had guests in my house this
weekend that maybe i made a delicious
lamb leg with rosemary and olive oil and
salt and pepper and a little cumin
there are some rumors about that and i
just want to completely dispel those
rumors those are totally
untrue i am a good american citizen
okay i'm a believer in eric garcetti our
mayor here in los angeles and i would
never never do anything against the
direct
orders of our leaders our dear dear
leaders so again i did not have several
people here i don't have anyone in my
house right
now didn't cook a delicious lamb and
there's
and and to the to the other rumor that i
bought a whole bunch of wine for
something that may be happening tonight
i just these are
these are baseless scurrilous rumors
and i will be referring them all to my
legal team because
obviously uh i am i am a true american
and by true american
i i comply i don't ask questions
and i know that eric garcetti
and gavin newsom are looking out for me
okay
now that we got that out of the way uh
we are covering four stories today i'll
give you a quick rundown then we'll dive
right into them
um so oh but before we do anything else
tomorrow night
because many of you have asked when are
we going to start doing the reuben
report
uh movie nights again tomorrow night
we're bringing it back we did a whole
bunch of them when lockdown started when
it was all kind of fun to be locked down
now it's become depressing
and dystopian but we're going to have
fun together at 5 00 p.m
eastern tomorrow on tuesday that's 8 p.m
eastern time so 5 p.m pacific 8 p.m
eastern we're doing a netflix watch
we're going to be watching v
for vendetta which i think is basically
the perfect movie
that we could possibly watch and i
actually did look in the youtube
comments
from friday when i mentioned that we're
going to be watching beaver vendetta a
lot of you are very excited
uh so uh create an account at
reubenreport.com all the info
is over there you can also download the
reuben report app which is on ios
and google play and then we'll watch the
movie all at the same time it'll be a
netflix watch
party and then we do a giant zoom chat
afterwards you guys can share your
feelings jump on video and that's
private and it'll be fun
and all that good stuff okay what are we
talking about today well first
let's start with bill gates bill gates
who
you'd know bill gates he's the windows
guy he's the microsoft guy he was a big
nerd
who then became a rich guy so he's a
little less nerdy uh
but he somehow is somebody that we all
seem to think
knows everything about everything and he
gets put on all of these tv shows as a
billionaire to tell us
what's good for us now he was on
jake tapper's show on cnn or i should
say the journalist formerly known as
jake tapper
and bill gates basically said we're
going to remain in lockdown
forever that's pretty much what he's
saying here but don't take my word for
it
let's listen to bill gates and jake
tapper
people in california are right now under
brand new stay-at-home orders
uh as hospitals there uh risk being
overwhelmed
um there are a lot of governors uh who
oppose bringing back
these lockdown orders and forcing
businesses
to close what do you think do you think
more states need to consider taking that
kind of drastic action
and the kind of drastic action we saw
when the pandemic first began or can
there be a more
nuanced approach well certainly
mask wearing uh has essentially no
downside they're not expensive
bars and restaurants in most of the
country will be closed as we go into
this wave and i think
sadly that's appropriate depending on
how severe
it is the decision about schools is much
more complicated because there
you know the benefits are pretty high
the amount of transmission
is not the same as in restaurants and
bars so
uh you know trade-offs will have to be
made but this
the next four to six months uh really
call on us
uh to to do our best because we can see
that this will end
and you don't want you know somebody you
love to be the last to die of
coronavirus
when do you think life will fully return
to what we thought of as
normal back in january no masks
no social distancing uh no other
protective measures
necessary
certainly by the summer we'll be
way closer to normal than we are now but
even through early 2022 unless we help
other countries
get rid of this disease and we get high
vaccination rates in our country
the risk of reintroduction will be there
and of course
the global economy will be uh slowed
down which hurts
america economically in a pretty
dramatic way
so we'll have starting in the summer
about nine months where a few things
like big public gatherings
uh will still be restricted but
you know we can see now that somewhere
between 12 to 18 months
and we have a chance if we manage it
well uh to get back to normal
i don't like you bill gates and as you
guys know i've been trying to control
the cursing around here so i'm going to
control
it for this but it ain't going to be
easy and actually i don't know what i'm
going to say in about two minutes from
now i don't do this with a script
i don't like you 12 to 18 months we
might get
normal these first off bill gates bill
gates is a tech guy
bill gates has done some good things in
the world and bill gates has given money
to charities and helped with some
schools and things like that
but bill gates isn't some authority on
this guys
we are now almost at christmas 2020 when
this freaking thing
started in march and the lockdown
started they said two weeks to flatten
the curve
as i said the other day if locking
everything down
masks everywhere destroying the economy
making sure
no one's doing anything ever then
california would look golden right now
and florida would look like a third
world world hellscape wouldn't it
except no no there's virtually no
difference
actually if anything florida is doing
better because they're getting closer to
something like herd immunity
this is absolutely insane and bill gates
it's like they bring him on and for some
reason we all do this we all do this
myself included
you see these people who have
accomplished some things and they've
made an awful lot of money
and you think that that makes them
experts on everything so what is bill
gates even doing on there now i know
bill gates likes to vaccinate people he
did some vaccination stuff
in in africa but what is he doing and by
the way
let's pull this up bill gates lives in a
154 million dollar mansion
in medina washington now i don't
begrudge bill gates any of the money you
know this i am a capitalist i believe in
free markets i believe in competition i
believe if you come up
with something great that you should you
should profit from it
and i don't even mind him buying other
companies and all of that stuff
but this man is living in a 154 million
dollar mansion try to imagine the staff
that i am sure
he has running through that house the
chefs
the cleaning people every the people
that take care of the grounds
all of that stuff he's got an engine of
people that are working for him either
with masks or without
he has no the truth is he has no care in
the world this guy's life has not been
affected
in any way while all of our lives have
and again i'm not bringing this up to
shame him for that freaking house if i
could afford it
i'd love to have it he lives happens to
live in a no tax state this is one of
the people who's always saying that
you know billionaires should be taxed
more rich people should be taxed more
for some reason he lives in washington
it's very
i mean why i can't really figure it out
um but
do you understand what's happening here
these people with extraordinary means
are telling us how to live you know i
tweeted on friday that if you want to
end the lockdowns
what you should do is suspend salaries
of politicians and the lockdown would
end in five minutes it's actually my
most viral tweet ever
it's got like 150 000 likes or something
like that but that's the point
we have politicians and then this sort
of elite
class this elite class that just want to
control
our lives forever he's also talking
about
not being transmitted in schools and
things we know that we know it's not
being transmitted in schools
this has nothing to do with covet
anymore if you guys don't get it
i'm going to just say this to until my
head explodes my head might explode
on one of these shows but this has the
lockdowns have nothing to do with covert
anymore this is an
absolute destruction of the economy and
i don't know exactly what the pieces are
like i don't know
you know this is where you could really
go into some conspiracy stuff and a
one-world government in the globalists
and all of that stuff
but it all sort of is piecing together
what does this have to do
with this pandemic we are supposed to be
able
to go out there and have a little risk
in our lives and live
and just because bill gates is worth a
gajillion dollars and everyone he knows
can live however they want while us
peons
have to have to pick up the crumbs it's
like that that's not good enough for me
and and jake tapper is just you know the
jabber in a way is the worst because he
used to be a real journalist the rest of
the
the rest of the cnn people are just are
just clowns
um but in essence you've got a
millionaire there and a billionaire
telling you
why the rest of us can't live that way
and again i don't begrudge them their
money
it's the point that they have access to
a lifestyle
that most people don't as they're the
ones that push the push away all of the
opportunity for the rest of us to live
it's just
absolutely nauseating but speaking of
nauseating
uh washington school district says that
asians aren't going to count as students
of color
anymore they are now going to be counted
as white students and
this is something i've been talking
about for probably three years because
as you guys know
the intersectional calculator the the
ridiculous social justice pyramid
it puts white straight people especially
white christians at the bottom
jews are kind of lumped in with them
because they're thought of as white
which
isn't even totally true obviously
religion
you could be any color religion right
you got white muslims you got black
muslims you got white jews you got black
jews blah blah blah but jews are
successful so you get thrown in with the
white christians none of this makes any
sense
there are there are millions of poor
white christians you're not privileged
just because of your skin color
you guys all understand this but what
happens is the more that these people
obsess over skin color
the more that they will discriminate
people
discriminate on people based on skin
color right
so if you're of indian descent or of
asian descent two groups that have come
to america
worked very hard nobody gave them
anything suffered discrimination right
you could look at old hollywood movies
what they were
doing with uh with asian people over the
years chinese people etc
uh they worked very hard they cared
about education they cared about family
played by the rules and then what
happened asian people of almost every
stripe
moved up the ladder became wealthy they
did well socioeconomically they did
education-wise they started owning
businesses all sorts of things but that
doesn't work
for indians that doesn't work for jews
it doesn't work for asian people so now
you have to actually punish them and
push them down the calculator
so that we can help other people because
this whole thing is absolutely
ridiculous so this is from fox news
north thurston public schools lumped
asians and white students together in
its equity report equity by the way is
the most dangerous word we've got right
now
and measured their achievements against
a student of color category that
includes black hispanic
native american pacific islander and
multi-racial students
moving forward district officials will
change how achievement data is observed
and apologize for the negative impact we
have caused and removed the monitoring
report
from our website look in essence guys
i just don't even know what to tell you
at this point if you don't get how
dangerous
social justice is it has nothing to do
with being social and it has
nothing to do with justice it's about
hurting people for working hard and
that's why they love the word equity and
not the word equality
all a free country can do is give you an
equal playing field meaning you're free
we're not going to have laws to
discriminate yes some of you are going
to start off poor some of you're going
to start off stupid
some of you are going to start off with
good families bad families some of you
are going to be born as crack babies
some of you are going to be born into
ultra elite families and have everything
and you might blow it and you might do
something with it
these are that's all what like the
gestalt of life is about gestalt good
word
that's what that's what life is chance
and risk and reward and all of those
things
the idea that they're trying to jam
equity down
our throats is dangerous it's anti-human
because it takes you out of the equation
you working hard it makes you the sum of
just what you look like
and is that how you want to be judged
well asians
you better you better get on the ball
here because they're coming for you
all right i'm moving fast today segment
three i can actually talk about a
politician i like it's a miracle
hallelujah
tulsi gabbard so tulsi gabbard who is a
congresswoman from
hawaii who as you know stayed in
the democratic primary situation she
basically stayed in it all the way
to the end and then they just sort of
forced her out and they were ignoring
her and not you know they kept changing
polling data so she couldn't get into
some debates could get into some others
i've had her on the show we've chatted a
couple times off air i think she is a
good decent person we have some
disagreements by the way some political
disagreements i don't care about that
i think she's fundamentally a good
person for those of you that don't know
a lot about tulsi the one thing that you
should
google about her is the moment in one of
the very early
debates where she absolutely
demolishes kamala harris on her record
about imprisoning people when she was
attorney general
here in california absolutely wrecks her
and you should see that clip because it
really is great uh
of course kamala dropped out shortly
after that and was polling basically at
zero and then they decided to make her
president because obviously joe biden
isn't going to be president i'm not even
sure any of that's going to
work out for them too but that's a
separate issue for today
uh but basically tulsi gabbard
did what we all know is right and i
and if you well i'll pause for a second
on that i was going to tell you about my
interview with abigail schreiert because
it's on the same topic but we'll get to
that at the end
uh but tulsi gabbard basically decided
to hit back
against the the trans movement not
against trans people but the trans
movement this is a quote
from the new york post democratic
representative tulsi gabbard hit back at
critics of legislation
she's introduced to prevent transgender
women
from competing in female sports and for
the care of
infant survivors of late term abortion
calling them hypocrites
a number of people called gabbard who
leaves congress this month transphobic
and a right-wing
shitheal on twitter among other
invectives
invectatives is that a word invectagives
i've never heard that word before
i welcome real criticism and debate
gabbard told the post saturday but my
so-called critics don't want to debate
the issues they just want to engage in
smears and slurs
and name calling in innuendo and a
little more from tulsi
identity policies politics is having an
incredibly destructive effect
on our country rather than recognizing
what connects all americans
it's being done to help people and
parties get in power and stay in power
by pitting individual americans against
each other
a truer statement has never been said
tulsi yes you are you are
absolutely right so let's let's just be
clear about this
her bill which she just introduced and
by the way she's stepping away from
politics right she's she's done at the
end of the year she's stepping away
and she's going to figure out some other
things to do but she's trying to do a
little bit of good
at the end in a party that has been
absolutely decimated
by the worst possible ideas and is being
led with a guy with dementia
and and a woman who would love to to
arrest everybody
in essence i'm being slightly hyperbolic
on that just a tiny bit
um what she is saying here in essence
the the bill that she is trying to get
past
prevents transgender women from
competing in female sports so this means
someone that was
biologically born a man and has those
physical attributes right we know bone
structure is different
we know muscle mass is different and
everything else you've all seen the
videos
of trans women meaning biological men
who transition
who then are beating the crap in
wrestling out of girls who are kicking
footballs farther and
dunking on people and and the rest of it
we all know something's not right there
that has
nothing to do with being transphobic i
have
no doubt in my mind that tulsi gabbard
has nothing but empathy and sympathy and
compassion
for trans people meaning that if you are
born one thing biologically and you wish
to live your life
as the opposite gender then go ahead and
transition and you should
as long as you do it you should be
treated exactly under the same
exactly the same way under the law as
everyone else the idea that she's
transphobic and this just shows you when
they when they use these were this
phobic word
it's such nonsense transphobic means she
has an irrational fear
phobia is an irrational fear do you
think tulsi gabbard
has an irrational fear of trans people i
have just
absolutely no doubt in my mind that she
does not but this is the stupidity that
they've created
and then of course you get all the the
the so-called tolerant
gender pronoun people on twitter telling
her how awful she is and she's a nazi
and a right-wing maniac and everything
else
she basically ran on trying to get us
out of wars you know which now
apparently
that that means you're a racist and a
nazi and a bigot in the right-wing
maniac and everything else
um just to her statement on identity
politics i mean you know i obviously
agree on that but i think what's
interesting about this is this is an
outgoing congresswoman who represents
the right ideas for the democratic party
now she's a little more big government
than than i would be at this point
that's okay that that's what america is
all about like you're supposed to debate
when and where the government should be
used and you're supposed to do it
respectfully and everything else and if
you haven't seen
my interview with with tulsa you know
we'll put it in the in the comment
section let's link to it
we'll link to it in the comment section
below so you can watch my i think we did
about an hour and a half together
and we talked about all these issues and
we agree on the big stuff and we agree
that america is a great country we don't
like identity politics
with a little bit of disagreement on
where taxes should be used and
i think we're kind of close on abortion
i mean it's just not even important what
those little differences are right
because
everyone loves little differences
instead of getting the big stuff right
the point is that the democratic party
had a choice to make along the road in
this past year
and the choice was either you go with
the crazy radical left nonsense
or you go with something that seems like
a sane democratic policy where
we want to help people using the state
that may not be some of the things that
conservatives like but we're different
we're democrats
we see more use for tax money to do
these things we see more use for the
federal government
we want to be an anti-war party blah
blah blah we want to be for the working
class
they chose all the wrong things under
the guise of that joe biden's a moderate
but obviously joe biden won't be in
charge
that's sort of where we're at at the
moment so the reason i thought this
story was important
wasn't specifically because of the
because of the trans
part of it um although i think what she
did was right and we all know it's right
and it's only a bunch of blue check
journalists and verified wackos who who
are arguing against that like we all
know that that's right
i don't know anyone i genuinely don't
know anyone in the public sphere
that is transphobic meaning that they
want laws
that stop trans people from living
whatever life they want to live
and if if you want some evidence of sort
of how crazy that lobby is
i'm sure many of you seen it already
because it has millions of views but i
did a speech
at university of new hampshire you could
just search dave rubin new hampshire
and we didn't even want to post this
video um because it was such
chaos with people screaming at me and
yelling that i'm a nazi and a bigot and
everything else
but there's a woman who turns out to be
trans in the audience and turns out
she's also a gender studies professor at
the university and she's calling me a
nazi and a bigot
she's trying to stop me from speaking of
course the university does nothing i
don't even care about that
but all i keep saying to her is i want
you to live with decency
and equality and i hope you find someone
that loves you and everything else and
her response to me
is you're a bigot and a racist so this
is a tiny bit of radical activists
who have in essence decimated liberals
and liberalism
and what you get left with is a
democratic party that doesn't know
what direction it is because it should
have been in the tulsi gabbard direction
and uh and in instead it's not by the
way i'm being told that
invectatives i've never heard that word
before
invectatives i'm getting the definition
of it it's insulting abusive or highly
critical language
so i'm learning a little something here
today too it's not just that you're
learning something maybe or
my goal isn't even to make you learn
anything my goal is to just by the end
of this thing hopefully you don't feel
dumber
because most of the time you watch
something on tv and you feel dumber at
the end like if you watch cnn for five
minutes
you feel dumber you feel dumber you have
a headache you're angry and you want to
punch people
i don't know that i can make you feel
smarter i just don't want you to feel
dumber that's all
all right let's move on to the final
story of the day by the way there's a
lot going on right now at this very
moment
related to electors and the uh the
election system
and what's going on with the fraud and
everything else i know if i even talk
about it i'll
i'll be banned from this wonderful free
speech haven known
as youtube uh but we'll have we'll have
more on that tomorrow because there's a
bunch
being unfurled at the moment and you can
check my twitter if you want to see some
some of the latest but uh the fourth
story i wanted to cover today and i
usually do three
but i want to do this fourth story
because you're probably not going to see
it on cnn because it involves the
brother
of one of the anchors of cnn
uh is a story that andrew cuomo who is
the governor
of uh new york who basically
is like the head of a mafia organization
at this point he's just
a bad dude who killed a lot of people we
all know that he sent all those
people back into the old age homes and
everything else in the midst of covet he
wrote a best
best-selling book about leadership
during covet as his state is in complete
lockdown and disarray right now i mean
these people it's like the hubris is
just
off the charts i wish i could be so
mindlessly
[Music]
in any event he is being accused of
sexual harassment from a progressive
activist by the name of lindsay boylan
she's also an urban planner
and let's uh let's just go through the
entire twitter thread here and then
we'll compare that to something else
that you might find interesting
this is the thread from lindsey boyle
and again she's a progressive activist
she has her pronouns in her bio this is
not a crazy right
winger this is not a scary conservative
or a white supremacist
she says my first experience of
workplace sexual harassment was when my
mom got her first real job
after graduating college when i was in
high school
she was so excited to be taken seriously
her boss
her boss isolate or her boss isolated
her and kissed her she never had that
type of job again
it was then when i learned how hard it
is for women how hard this world can be
for us when we are trying to be taken
seriously and help
our community how easily jerks can
destroy the lives of women
and i promised myself i would never let
those kind of guys win
i would work hard my whole life to put
myself in positions of power to change
things to end
the violence and corruption give voice
to the voiceless
i am not stopping i refuse i will never
give up
and now we're going to get into the part
about cuomo specifically
yes new york governor andrew cuomo
sexually harassed me for years
many saw it and watched i could never
anticipate what to expect
would i be grilled on my work which was
very good or harassed about my looks or
would it be both in the same
conversation this was
this was the way for years not knowing
what to expect what's the most upsetting
part aside from knowing that no one
would do a damn
thing even when they saw it no one and i
know
i'm not the only woman i'm angry to be
put in this situation at all that's
because i am a woman
i can work hard my whole life to better
myself and help others and yet still
fall
victim as countless women over
generations have mostly silent
i hate that some men like andrew cuomo
abuse their power
so okay i don't know if what she's
saying is true or not
she does say one interesting thing in
there which is i never knew what to
expect would i be grilled on my
work or harassed about my looks now if
you're grilled on your work that's not
sexual harassment but if those things
are happening at the same time
or back and forth i think one of the
problems here is people think that any
criticism
somehow becomes harassment but putting
that aside
for a year and a half basically we were
told to believe all women right we were
always told to believe
all women got to believe them all no
women could be liars you must believe
all women
well now and we've seen this
consistently whenever it comes out that
they go after a lefty they go after a
democrat they don't don't we didn't mean
that we didn't mean all women we meant
we met when they were going after the
crazy right wingers
you see what i'm saying here guys so
look i don't know if this is true
i have no idea by the way right now uh
according to some some people in the
media uh
andrew cuomo is being vetted to be joe
biden's attorney general which means he
would basically be in charge of the law
enforcement apparatus
of the country uh that's according to
the ap so this is this is
serious stuff but look if we were to
believe all women then it seems like
everybody should be reporting on this
right we should be reporting on this
uh but i thought you know there's
something interesting here because i'm
not seeing a lot of people reporting on
it
and then i did a little a little
googling and i looked on the
twitter machine there and i thought
maybe they're the the news organizations
are treating this a little bit
differently they treated something else
so let's look at
usa today politics uh
and the image you're seeing on the left
is this is from
yesterday or today the aid has not yet
provided any validating evidence for the
allegations or specific details on
the harassment cuomo's office has denied
the claim okay so that's fine she hasn't
provided any direct evidence okay we're
going to treat this maturely
we're mature people we're journalists
for god's sakes
now on the right and this is from you
may remember this from about two years
ago remember that uh
that brett kavanaugh hearing when he was
trying to become supreme court justice
and everyone said he was the
the sort of long-term gang rape man of
the world
democratic presidential candidates are
calling for brett kavanaugh to be
impeached after the new york times
published an essay containing new
allegations of sexual misconduct
i i could have grabbed a gazillion
headlines like this there was no
evidence that brett kavanaugh ever
sexually assaulted anybody all there
were were allegations the same thing
that is happening here
so we know there is a double standard if
you're a democrat you're they're going
to bend over backwards for you they're
going to hide things for you
they're going to use trickery in
language misleading
uh headlines that are disconnected from
the story and if you're on the right
you're a gang rapist you're a nazi and
you're a bigot
lori lorre we got a lot of work to do to
clean up this mess
okay guys uh here's the deal tomorrow
night
5 p.m pacific 8 pm eastern i will be
watching
v for vendetta it is an absolutely
spectacular movie if you haven't seen it
and even if you have seen it it's one of
those movies that the more you watch the
better it gets
and there's so many parallels about the
crazy lockdowns we're
having right now the authoritarian
government the overreach the fear
all of those things it's just it's just
the perfect movie so join us at
reubenreport.com this is for
supporters only so you just create an
account see what's going on there we'll
have info on the netflix watch party and
then we're gonna do a massive
zoom afterwards again that's
reubenreport.com and tomorrow tuesday 5
pm pacific 8 pm
eastern and as i started saying before
watch part one of my interview with
abigail schreier which is up right now
and abigail wrote a really wonderful
book
on the sudden explosion
of young teen girls that are suddenly
transitioning and the in
transitioning to to boys and in effect
the entire
cultural political machine and
scientific
machine that is driving it and she
really exposes a ton of it
the book is absolutely spectacular and
you may remember a couple weeks ago
target banned the book because literally
two people tweeted at them to get rid of
the book and then there was an outcry
and now they've put the book back
i interviewed her a few days ago and we
wanted to hold the interview because the
book wasn't even restocked
until this week so now you can go ahead
and get the book too so part one of my
interview is up on youtube right now the
full things up at reubenreport.com
i'll see you guys tomorrow for movie
night we're back here all week
and then and then and then actually at
the end of this week after friday
we're shutting down our operation for
the rest of the year i want my guys to
have
time to enjoy families and and christmas
and
new year's and everything else but we
will be putting up some best dubs stuff
and some other interesting
things and then and i'm actually going
to dip out for a little bit too because
i think everybody could use a little
break from the craziness but we are here
every day this week oh and i'm on fox
and friends tomorrow morning at like
something like 8 a.m
uh eastern i'm not sure it's super early
i'll be up at 4am okay i feel like i've
been talking a lot have a great day
and i'll see you tomorrow